[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit
christian sievers live vom g7 gipfel auf
schloss elmau
guten abend hinein aus einem bayerischen
bergidyll das jetzt gleichzeitig einer
der am aufwändigsten gesicherten orte
dieser welt ist die mächtigen der g77
führende industrieländer gemeinsam von
angesicht zu angesicht und mit blick
aufs wettersteingebirge es gibt viel
kritik an diesem treffen und dem
gigantischen aufwand auch jetzt wieder
gleichzeitig gibt es ja gerade jetzt
dermaßen große herausforderungen und
sorgen dass viele menschen auf der welt
sehnlichst warten dürften auf konkrete
ergebnisse auf neue ideen auf lösungen
aus
diesem abgeschiedenen ort oberhalb von
garmisch partenkirchen sollen antworten
kommen der bundeskanzler hat seine g7
kollegen eingeladen in 1 650 euro pro
nacht luxushotel er hat geschlossenheit
versprochen und entschiedenes handeln
was das konkret heißt was auf dem spiel
steht darüber werden wir sie in den
nächsten 30 minuten informieren wir
beginnen mit thomas reichert und den
politischen akzenten des auftakt tages
es beginnt damit dass die gastgeber dass
olaf scholz erst mal warten muss joe
biden sollte jetzt eigentlich kommen
aber wo bleibt er denn bei all der
minutiösen gipfel planung war das nicht
eingeplant anders als blaue überziehe
für journalisten füße zum schutz eines
sehr roten teppichs
dann kommt beiden von scholz wirkt
irgendwie erleichtert
das waren gute botschaft dass wir alle
geeint geblieben sind sagt scholz
deshalb tut ihn offensichtlich nicht
erwartet
das war zu keinem geringen teil wegen
dir ganz in ernst entgegnete
der oft als zauderer kritisiert wurde
hat sich das warten ja schon gelohnt
nicht nur für shorts für die g7
insgesamt ist das ein gipfel der
selbstvergewisserung es geht um
geschlossenheit gegenüber russland bei
waffenlieferungen sanktionen
wirtschaftshilfen dem eigenen land das
da bin ich sehr froh dass wir hier so
viel zeit haben miteinander zu sprechen
ganz entfernt von den typischen
formalisierten abläufen und auch so dass
jeder das sagt was ihm wirklich auf dem
herzen liegt das hat schon gleich bei
der ersten sitzung so geklappt boris
johnson allerdings sagt sowieso ständig
was ihm auf dem herzen liegt und er hat
gleich eine wichtige frage
an oder aus ist sei so heiß
großbritanniens premier ist dafür die
jacken an zu behalten denn
wir alle müssen zeigen dass wir härter
sind dass putin findet johnson die
anderen g7 finden dass offenbar auch
einige der mächtigen vergessen beim
offenen austausch fast all die ohren und
mikrofone die mit hören das kann er dass
justin turbo für das sie nicht
lasst uns weg von den medien gehen war
der und weiß wohl warum foto wurde
meiner takt als er über trump lästerten
breiten wiederum macht früh klar wer bei
den g7 kommen keine ist noch vor beginn
des gipfels verkündet er dass die
geschrieben am ende unter anderem
beschließen sollen einen importstopp für
russisches gold dass russland sonst sich
milliarden dollar einbringen und biden
will einen umbau des energiemarktes die
ganze welt für die auswirkungen von
russlands brutalen krieg in der ukraine
und auf unseren energiemärkten wir
brauchen weltweit die anstrengungen um
in projekte für saubere energie zu
investieren und sicherzustellen dass
kritische infrastrukturen den
klimawandel standhalten können
am abend geht es diesmal ohne jacketts
um weitere waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine darum geschlossen zu bleiben
gegen russland bei einem krieg dennoch
lange dauern könnte
die präsidentin der eu kommission des
bei uns ursula von der leyen frau von
der leyen guten abend viele bürgerinnen
und bürger fragen sich angesichts dessen
was man hier erlebt wozu das ganze wozu
dieser aufwand haben sie heute einen
satz gehört eine information bekommen
die sie so über videokonferenzen niemals
erhalten hätten mit sicherheit
und es machte das wissen wir ja alle
seid cockpit und den ewigen
videokonferenzen es macht einen
unterschied ob man sich persönlich
trifft oder ob man sich über den
bildschirm sieht und hier haben wir ganz
intensiv den ganzen tag zusammen
gesessen und eigentlich die ganzen
themen und probleme der welt durchgekaut
wir kennen uns gut sie eine gruppe die
sehr zusammengewachsen ist jetzt durch
den schrecklichen krieg dem russland in
der ukraine ausgelöst hat haben wir uns
sehr regelmäßig und sehr häufig
gesprochen aber hier noch mal so ganz in
klausur zu gehen ganz eng beieinander zu
setzen uns durchzukauen das ist schon
sehr wichtig jetzt kommen sie gerade vom
arbeits abendessen da sagen viele auch
aus dem internen kreis das ist
eigentlich die wichtigste veranstaltung
des ganzen treffens und das liegt nicht
haben ich habe es mir aufgeschrieben
haben mona kalbsfilet in heu gegart das
bestimmt auch sehr gut wahr
was ist denn dabei rausgekommen gab es
was können sie uns verraten gab es einen
durchbruch hat jemand tacheles geredet
gab es ein konkretes ergebnis jetzt nach
diesem essen ganz aktuell ganz wichtig
ist ja dass wir uns untereinander
abstimmen will wir die großen probleme
angehen erstmal natürlich wie
unterstützen wir weiter die ukraine und
das ist eine breite palette an themen
liedern durchgesprochen so aber gab es
ein ergebnis sie formulieren jetzt die
frage ihr auf dem tisch liegen aber was
wären denn die antworten die g7 jetzt
also zb bei dem ganzen thema
lebensmittelkrise dass wir eng
zusammenarbeiten müssen erst mal
finanziell unterstützen die länder die
jetzt wirklich in not sind durch putins
krieg dann zweitens dass wir konsequent
uns darüber unterhalten müssen wo man
eigentlich den weizen den es weltweit
gibt wie man den fair verteilt drittens
dass wir uns zusammentun wollen dass wir
in den ländern die völlig abhängig sind
von ukrainischen oder russischen weizen
in der mittelfristig hinkriegen dass die
selber ihre lebensmittel anbauen damit
sie ihre unabhängigkeit auch wieder
bekommen also ganz konkret auch wo wir
eng zusammenarbeiten wollen und wie wir
das thema angehen wollen was ist mit
hilfe für die ukraine ganz konkrete
hilfe weitere möglicherweise auch
langfrist hilfe das hört man heute hier
immer wieder es ist eben keine sache
mehr von wochen und monaten sondern
offensichtlich von jahren zumindest hört
man dass wir werden der ukraine bei
stehen solange es nötig ist das war das
grund motto heute abend wenn es jahre
dauert und viele viele milliarden euro
kostet dann stehen wir der ukraine zur
seite denn hier ist geht es darum ob die
demokratin sich durchsetzen oder ob sich
der aggressor durchsetzt der brutale der
brutal die ukraine überfallen hat und
andere autokraten auf der welt schauen
sich sehr genau an ob man mit brutaler
macht militärischer macht heutzutage
noch grenzen verschieben kann und länder
über fallen kann oder ob die demokratien
aufstehen und mit ihrer eigenen kraft
und das ist vor allem die
wirtschaftliche kraft eine entsprechende
antwort geben und sagen halt bis hierhin
und nicht weiter sie haben punkte ist
schon genannt klimakrise energiekrise
natürlich der krieg in der ukraine
ich nehme an sie haben wahrscheinlich
auch noch nie eine so verfahrene
situation in so vielen feldern erlebt
kann man sagen dass es der wichtigste
g7-gipfel den es jemals gab
ich kann das jetzt natürlich nicht ohne
weiteres sagen denn ich bin bei vielen
g7 gipfel in den letzten zwanzig dreißig
jahren natürlich nicht dabei gewesen
aber die dichte der krisen die ist schon
einmalig wir kommen ja kaum aus café
drauf raus wir haben uns gerade wieder
langsam wirtschaftlich erholt wir haben
diskutiert über die lieferketten die
zusammengebrochen sind durch koppelt und
dann schlägt dieser krieg zu und dann
die energiekrise die tauss diesem krieg
aus resultiert und dann noch die
lebensmittelkrise und die klimakrise ist
es genau diese kulminieren von krisen
die uns jetzt beschäftigen wenn dieser
gipfel dann so so wichtig ist dann ist
ja auch die gefahr des scheiterns
besonders groß oder wenn nämlich dieser
gipfel am ende kein richtiges ergebnis
bringt ich erlebt genau das gegenteil
ich erlebe dass wir gerade dadurch dass
wir so zusammengewachsen sind und vor
allen dingen weil wir wissen das ist
nicht nur um die g 7 da geht und
menschen die dort leben sondern es geht
um die großen probleme der welt und wer
wenig wie er muss verantwortung
übernehmen und führung zeigen
führung zeigen verantwortung übernehmen
was sagen sie denn den ländern im
globalen süden wie es hier immer heißt
die dann auch morgen hier dazustoßen
werden die sagen das kostet uns leben
sogar wir haben schwierigkeiten über die
runden zu kommen wir haben
schwierigkeiten mit den hohen
energiepreisen
leichter einfach ein aufruf zur
solidarität
es muss mehr kommen also erstens freue
ich mich dass wir morgen partnerländer
eingeladen haben internationale
organisationen aber auch die finanz die
internationalen finanzinstitute
und wir müssen zum beispiel bei den
energiepreisen müssen wir ernsthaft
daran gehen werden das ganze thema
ölpreis grenze zum beispiel besprochen
denn die hohen ölpreise sind kaum noch
zu bewältigen für die entwicklung also
eine preisgrenze für russisches öl
speziell das war eine idee von joe biden
aber ist sie tatsächlich auch am ende so
dass sie jetzt spruchreife wie haben sie
miteinander diskutiert und inzwischen
sitzen unsere fachleute zusammen und
arbeiten details aus und es ist richtig
denn es kann ja nicht sein dass putin
seine richtig teuer am weltmarkt
verkauft und damit seine kriegskasse
erfüllt während andere länder zum
beispiel die entwicklungsländer in die
knie gehen bei diesen preisen da muss
aber daneben auch die welt
zusammenstehen und sagen wir sind nicht
mehr bereit diese
astronomischen preise zu zahlen sondern
wir werden eine preisgrenze einziehen
alle müssen damit machen und wir werden
sicherstellen dass ja fair bezahlt wird
für das öl aber nicht mehr in der höhe
das ist putins kriegskasse füllt das ist
ein thema zum beispiel was heute
intensiv diskutiert wurde und jetzt mit
den fachleuten wie gesagt ausgearbeitet
wird ganz kurz vor von allein ein
g20-gipfel im november mit präsident
putin mit am tisch ist so etwas denkbar
für sie eines ist ganz klar es wird kein
business as usual geben also nicht
normalität aber das klingt nicht so als
ob sie sagen da darf keiner hinfahren
von uns allen wenn putin da ist ich
glaube das müssen wir miteinander hier
besprechen es ist auch wichtig ihm ins
gesicht zu sagen was wir von ihm halten
und was wir von dieser art des handelns
halten und wir müssen sehr genau
überlegen ob wir das gesamte g20
lahmlegen da plädiere ich nicht dafür
ich halte das für ein viel zu wichtiges
gremium
ich glaube es ist besser
zu sagen wenn er denn kommt ihm ins
gesicht zu sagen was wir davon halten
und dann soll er mal position auch
beziehen also meines erachtens ist g20
zu wichtig auch für die
entwicklungsländer die schwellenländer
als dass wir uns dieses gremium kaputt
machen lassen sollten auch von wieder
von putin ok interessante informationen
zum schluss noch eine frage sie sind
hier wirklich im berg idylle den ganzen
tag kriegen überhaupt nichts mit von den
protesten der der gegner von g7 aber
auch von den protesten der anwohner
unten im tal ist das der richtige weg um
mit bürgerinnen und bürgern und deren
sorgen umzugehen also ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich finde diese prozesse solange
sie friedlich sind ich finde sie gut
weil sie die polizei ist er dazwischen
ja aber sie dürfen nicht vergessen das
ist ein zeichen lebendiger demokratie
und das ist nicht überall auf der welt
der fall ich mein wenn wir uns gerade
über autokraten unterhalten da wäre das
unmöglich zweitens
auch hier sage ich wir müssen die kritik
hören und wir müssen mit dieser kritik
uns auseinandersetzen und der dritte
punkt ist aber natürlich wenn sich so
viele staats und regierungschefs hier
treffen dann ist es eben auch ein wert
an sich dass man in kleinen kreis
zusammen sitzen kann und die wichtigen
themen der welt diskutieren kann sagt
ursula von der leyen ich danke ihnen
ganz herzlich für das gespräch
dankeschön und
sie haben sie eine lichtstimmung gemerkt
das gespräch haben wir aus termingründen
vor einer knappen stunde aufgezeichnet
jetzt läuft hier hinter mir im
schlosshotel laufen die gespräche nach
dem dinner auch wieder mit ursula von
der leyen und auch im abgeschotteten g7
hotel auf 1000 und acht metern höhe ist
der lärm der hubschrauber zu hören die
die regierungschefs transportieren und
zwischendurch auch delegationen und
presse nämlich dann wenn auf den straßen
unten kein durchkommen mehr ist ein
rekordverdächtiges aufgebot an polizei
und armee soll sicherheit garantieren
und proteste fernhalten das treibt
mitunter blüten etwa wenn 130 kühe unter
polizeischutz durch den
sicherheitsbereich getrieben werden es
gibt die die das system der g7 generell
ablehnen und die die sich fragen was
soll der aufwand bringen aber auch für
die demonstranten hat sich die weltlage
geändert vielleicht kommt deshalb bisher
deutlich weniger als erwartet jutta
sonnenwald hat mehr dazu
auf knapp 3000 metern über dem g7
tagungsort am gipfel der zugspitze
appellieren sie an die sieben
mächtigsten staats und regierungschefs
im tal junge greenpeace aktivisten
fordern frieden und mehr klimaschutz
die klimakrise die ist nicht mehr weit
entfernt ist jetzt wohnen wir jetzt
nicht handeln dann ist zu spät und dann
haben wir unseren planeten kaputt
gemacht für den angenehmen und das auch
unten im zentrum von garmisch
partenkirchen wollen sie den g-7-staaten
den marsch blasen hunderte menschen
ziehen durch die marktgemeinde mit den
klassischen g7 protest themen wie hunger
armut und die globale wirtschaftliche
ungleichheit aber auch der krieg gegen
die ukraine und seine folgen treiben sie
um zum beispiel zu inflation die uns ja
alle gerade betrifft auch im freistaat
jetzt kann uns das leben nicht mehr
leisten so mieten steigen die
lebensmittelpreise werden immer höher es
wurden im vorfeld überhaupt keine
minderjährigen menschen gefragt was ihre
meinung zu den wichtigen themen ist ich
bin 17 jahre alt da sitzen leute die
sind vier mal so alt wie ich und
diskutieren über ganz zukunft
entscheidende fragen die klimawandel
krieg wie es weiter geht es mit der
wirtschaft ob vielleicht ein anderes
wirtschaftssystem brauchen das geht
einfach nicht auf den ersten blick
scheint es zwischen den themen der
protestierenden und denen der
regierenden gar nicht so große
differenzen zu geben im gegenteil sowohl
bundeskanzler scholz als gastgeber
seinen mitstreitern die gründung eines
klima clubs vorschlagen bei dem alle
staaten zusammenarbeiten gegen den
menschengemachten klimawandel warum
dennoch der protest wir begleiten die
politik der g7 schon seit einiger zeit
und was wir hören sind immer warme worte
vollmundige versprechungen aber es
folgen keine taten und genau das ist das
problem deswegen müssen sich die g7 bei
dem gipfel in ellmau dazu bekennen
konkrete taten konkrete entscheidungen
konkrete handlungen auf den weg zu
bringen ihr unmut gilt aber auch dem
riesen aufwand und gipfeltreffen dieser
18.000 polizisten aus ganz deutschland
sollen dafür sorgen dass das groß event
auf schloss elmau nicht durch solche
proteste gestört wird etwa 180 millionen
euro kostet die politische alpen show
hätte man das geld ganz anders verwenden
können g7 gipfel in ellmau und protest
dagegen ein déjà vu für die einwohner
garmisch partenkirchens die das ganze
spektakel inklusive großräumiger
abschottung ihres geburtstags schon mal
vor sieben jahren erlebt haben für
oliver derby mit seinem eishockey laden
ist das ganze der geist eines
geschlossenen über sechs bis sieben
monate wir haben dadurch unser umsatz
ist auf null unsere schule muss man
absagen im august
das ist eine schule für kinder zwischen
vier und 14 jahren
auch das können wir nicht nur finden
weil seine stelle neben belegt dass
durch die bundespolizei während die
polizei alles im blick hat rund um das
gipfel geschehen im oberbayerischen
elmau protestieren sie weiter im tal und
auf dem berg für frieden und eine
bessere welt
zentrale kraft der g7 bleiben die usa
gerade nach der ära trump der solche
treffen ja immer genüsslich und geradezu
chaotisch sabotierte el mati wissen ist
bei uns unser usa-korrespondent guten
abend elmar jetzt also joe biden der
hier auch immer ganz weit vorne redet
und immer am längsten redet kann er denn
diese erwartungen erfüllen hat ja eine
ganze menge probleme zu hause ja also
beiden ist ein anderer ganz verrückten
lage er hat bei ge simulator etwas
geschafft was ihm zu hause nicht
gelingen will nämlich einigkeit und
versöhnung und deswegen ist das hier so
was wie eine flucht nach vorn er will er
muss gewissermaßen dieses bündnis hier
zusammen halten die geschlossenheit darf
nicht bröckeln weil das wäre ja
rückenwind für russland aber auch für
china und ein amerikanischer präsident
der innenpolitisch schwächele schwächelt
und der außenpolitisch versagt ihr wäre
krachend gescheitert und deswegen muss
er etwas hier vom gesehen befindet würde
was ist denn von joe biden konkret zu
erwarten hat ja diesen preis deckel für
russisches öl ins spiel gebracht das
klingt erst mal wie eine sehr clevere
idee weil die am besten gerade die
europäer beziehen jahr noch momentan öl
aus russland und wenn man eine
preisobergrenze beschließen würde also
würde sagen wir zahlen halt nicht mehr
dafür kein putin sich entscheiden ob er
die geschäfte weiter macht dann könnte
man damit verhindern dass russland
weiter gewinne macht er verdient ja
momentan mehr als vor dem ausbruch des
krieges und das ist eine idee die könnte
auch anderen gefallen staaten wie indien
beispielsweise oder indonesien die ja
hier vertreten sind und wenn die
mitmachen würden dann wäre das
gewissermaßen eine koalition der
willigen gegen russland eine erweiterung
der geschlossenheit das könnte allen ein
stück weit gefallen aber man wird sich
im grundsatz darauf verständigen viele
details dieses plans ist die sind noch
unklar einmal für den moment ganz
herzlichen dank
sanktionen russland ukraine das waren
tatsächlich schon themen beim letzten g
7 treffen hier in der immer das waren
themen schon 2015 jetzt natürlich noch
mal deutlich drängen und wie um zu
unterstreichen wie dringend diese
probleme sind schlugen heute wieder
russische raketen in der ukrainischen
hauptstadt kiew ein zum ersten mal seit
wochen russlands präsident und seine
botschaft in die bayerischen berge dara
hassanzadeh berichtet
nahezu täglich kommt der luftalarm aufs
handy unterbricht das leben der menschen
in kiew doch seit drei wochen folgte auf
die warnungen kein luft schlag mehr bis
heute in den morgenstunden schlugen
mehrere russische raketen in kiew ein
sie trafen dieses wohnhaus ein mann
starb bei dem angriff und sechs weitere
bewohner ringen um ihr leben in
anbetracht der zerstörung hat auch
bürgermeister klitschko sogar noch
schlimmeres befürchtet
erst gebäude wurde zerstört und wir
wissen dass dort noch menschen unter den
trümmern sind sie leben noch die
einsatzkräfte versuchen sie zu retten
sie raus zu bekommen es gibt viel rauch
und wir alle geben unser bestes die
verschütteten so schnell wie möglich zu
bergen
fieberhaft und unter lebensgefahr suchen
die einsatzkräfte in den trümmern nach
eingeschlossenen menschen es ist ein
wettlauf gegen die zeit
rettung für dieses mädchen sie ist
sieben jahre alt sie schlief als die
raketen explodierten
die russischen raketen schlugen gezielt
dem käfer zentrum ein in einem viertel
das geprägt ist von
universitäten restaurants und
kunstgalerien
vielleicht ist es symbolisch dieser
angriff in diesen tagen
viele ukraine werden die heutigen
luftangriffe als botschaft moskaus an
den g 7 gipfel und als reaktion von dort
wünschen sie sich weitere lieferungen
von schweren waffen
ja dann bringen wir jetzt unsere
korrespondenten mit dazu in die sendung
axel sturm zunächst in moskau genannt
axel es gibt hier in ellmau heute keine
einzige runde kein einziges statement in
dem es nicht im grunde immer wieder um
russland ginge wie genau beobachtet denn
präsident putin wie es um die hier immer
wieder beschworene einigkeit des westens
bestellt ist
ja man muss da heute in moskau schon
ganz genau hinschauen wenn man mit
bekommen wollte was da in deutschland in
helmer stattfindet denn offensichtlich
ist es nicht gewesen dass ein g 7 gipfel
tagt das liegt zum einen daran dass die
politische führung des landes auch
präsident putin in keinster weise auch
nicht in einem halbsatz oder in einer
kurzen bemerkung in irgendeiner weise
stellung bezogen hat und das liegt auch
daran dass im russischen fernsehen
dieses event so gut wie gar nicht
gecovert wird es gab einen kurzen
fernsehbeitrag den ich heute abend
gesehen habe und das war es aber die
politische begleitmusik die gab es ja
schon vergangene woche präsident putin
hat ja teilgenommen an brics gipfel also
am gipfel zwischen brasilien russland
indien china und südafrika
er hob damals schon
hervor dass dieser gipfel dieses
wirtschaftsbündnis sozusagen das
wichtigste der welt sei und dieses
bündnis das muss man sagen steht ja
schließlich auch für 40 prozent der
weltbevölkerung und fast ein viertel des
welt bruttoinlandsprodukts und
außenminister lawrow vereinen baku in
aserbaidschan
der war sehr deutlich im vorfeld des g 7
gipfel sagte er müsste man müsse davon
ausgehen dass die eu und die nato
momentan eine koalition schmieden würden
um in einen großen kriegen gegen
russland zu ziehen das war vergangene
woche axel vielen dank das stichwort es
schon gefallen china miriam stein es für
uns in peking hallo miriam china ist
hier in ellmau nicht dabei aber ständig
ist spürt man geradezu der elefant im
raum kann man vielleicht sagen wie kommt
denn in china an was die g7 hier als
demonstrative konkurrenz initiative zu
china vorstellen gerade im bereich
globaler infrastruktur
also offiziell spielt er gipfel hier
bisher eher keine rolle in den
abendnachrichten hier im staatsfernsehen
war es kein thema aber
intern da schaut die chinesische führung
natürlich ganz genau was in ellmau
passiert und die frage die alle
beschäftigt ist wie stabil ist denn
dieses westliche bündnis das durch
putins angriffskrieg nochmal enger
zusammengerückt ist und das geht vor
allem um die frage wie stabil ist denn
dieses bündnis auch auf der langstrecke
also wenn das jetzt der krieg in der
ukraine noch weitere monate dauert
langstrecke das ist ja die disziplin in
der china sich für ziemlich unschlagbar
hält weil das system hier der führungen
die freiheit gibt weil die kurzfristige
zustimmung des volkes die ist hier ja
nicht notwendig china ist auf jeden fall
nutznießer der aktuellen situation
es nutzt zum beispiel die
wirtschaftliche situation aus also die
sanktionen des westens die reißen ein
loch und da kann china ein stoßen zum
beispiel ist russland seit dieser woche
der größte öllieferant chinas und es
gibt noch ein anderes thema das china
ganz recht ist das ist dass der westen
so konzentriert ist auf dem krieg in der
ukraine und auf die folgen daraus und
das hilft china bei die deshalb die
chinesischen themen ziemlich grund
rücken also über
menschenrechtsverletzungen in china oder
über auch über die beschränkung der
freiheitsrechte in hongkong dafür ist
gerade echt wenig aufmerksamkeit da
insgesamt wird china nicht so sehr
darauf schauen was in ellmau gesprochen
wird sondern vielmehr auch bei der
konkurrenz zur seidenstraße die du
gerade angesprochen hast darauf welche
taten denn diesen diesen worten wirklich
folgen werden bereit für die langstrecke
das ist etwas was wir hier heute auch
den gesamten tag von der g 7 gehört
haben ja das war die sicht aus moskau
und peking ganz herzlichen dank dafür
und viele weitere geschichten und
informationen rund um g7 haben unsere
kolleginnen und kollegen von zdf heute
online für sie und zwar auf allen
kanälen
und jetzt die weiteren nachrichtenlage
an diesem sonntag und die hat hans wolf
im blick
angesichts der gestiegenen energiekosten
und der hohen inflation will
bundeskanzler scholz medienberichten
zufolge eine steuer- und abgabenfrei
einmalzahlung durch die arbeitgeber
vorschlagen im gegenzug sollten die
gewerkschaften weitere fronten auf einen
teil der lohnsteigerungen verzichten
anfang juli will der kanzler mit
spitzenvertretern der arbeitnehmer und
arbeitgeber darüber beraten wie die
preisentwicklung in den griff zu
bekommen ist
zum abschluss des parteitags der linken
in erfurt sind die delegierten im
parteiinternen streit um eine
positionierung zum ukraine krieg der
linie der partei spitze gefolgt in dem
beschluss wird russland eine
imperialistische politik vorgeworfen und
der angriff auf die ukraine verurteilt
vor der invasion im februar hatten viele
in der partei nur verständnis für
russische interessen geäußert
wegen personalengpässen an deutschen
flughäfen will die bundesregierung die
möglichkeit zur befristeten anstellung
ausländischer arbeitskräfte schaffen
schon ab juli sollen die hilfskräfte zum
beispiel bei der gepäckabfertigung
eingesetzt werden können an dem
flughafen hatte die urlaubssaison zum
teil chaotisch begonnen laut einer
studie fehlen an deutschen flughäfen
rund 7000 2 wird fachkräfte
zum sport bei der schwimm-em in budapest
hat die deutsche freiwasser staffel gold
gewonnen das quartett aus leer bei
oliver klemt leonie beck und florian
wellbrock holte den wm titel auf der 4 x
1,5 kilometer strecke vor den
schwimmerinnen aus ungarn und italien
und zum auftakt der wassersprung
wettbewerbe in budapest gab es für das
deutsche synchron duo barthel rüdiger
vom drei-meter-brett wm bronze hinter
den teams aus china und großbritannien
letzte wettkampftag heute bei den
finales in berlin den deutschen
meisterschaften in 14 sportarten einer
der leichtathletik höhepunkte am abend
weitsprung mit olympiasiegerin marie
hamburg sie gewann den wettbewerb mit
einer weite von 6 metern 85 und holte
damit ihren sechsten titel als deutsche
meisterin
es gibt aktuelle unwetterwarnungen des
deutschen wetterdienstes gewarnt wird
vor schweren gewittern mit starkregen
und hagel sowie sturmböen in teilen von
baden-württemberg und jetzt die
wetteraussichten morgen im osten und
südosten noch länger sonnig und bis zu
35 grad heiß sonst bei 19 bis 26 grad
viele schauer und gewitter lokal
unwetter durch starkregen hagel und
schweren sturmböen
die weiteren aussichten in den nächsten
tagen eine mischung aus sonnigen
abschnitten und weiteren schauern und
gewittern bei 22 bis 31 grad
ja und bevor wir auf die politischen
aussichten hier auf schloss elmau beim
g7-gipfel schauen noch ein ganz
besonderes bild das hier oben vor ein
paar minuten entstanden ist ein bild das
erinnert an dem moment 2015 auf dieser
legendären bank im garten zwischen
bundeskanzlerin den damaligen
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel und dem
damaligen us präsident barack obama auch
heute die regierungschefs legere kann
man sagen es war sehr sehr heiß heute
den ganzen tag über besonders im manual
marco der französische präsident aber
eins ist auch klar damals das waren
unbeschwerten zeiten
el mati wissen ist noch mal bei uns
immer gucken wir nach vorne politischen
aussichten auf morgen da sind die länder
des so genannten globalen südens hiermit
eingeladen weil das eben nicht nur g7
westlich orientiert sein soll wie kann
man diese länder die ja bei vielem was
die g7 hier vorhaben durchaus skeptisch
sind einbinden eigentlich nur mit taten
viele dieser schwellen und
entwicklungsländer sehen ein bisschen
ein bisschen fassungslos kann man sagen
dass die usa und ihre verbündete weit
über 50 milliarden dollar an hilfen für
die ukraine und für deren nachbarstaaten
zur verfügung stellen während viele von
diesen corona hilfen die man letztes
jahr versprochen hat eben immer noch
nicht bei ihnen angekommen sind da ist
so der eindruck entstanden wenn es ernst
wird kümmert ihr euch nur um euch selbst
und um diesen ruf der doppelmoral zu
brechen muss diese westliche
wertegemeinschaft eben liefern taten
bringen und das haben wir heute ein
stück weit gesehen 600 milliarden dollar
für infrastrukturprojekte für
kommunikations- und energienetze und
ähnliches und wenn morgen daneben
staaten wie indonesien indien senegal
südafrika und argentinien den eindruck
haben die machen das die setzen das um
man könnte das strahlkraft entwickeln
auf viele länder die die g7 vielleicht
nur für einen elitären club halten m at
was einen ganz herzlichen dank auch
heute abend wieder ja ein signal der
entschlossenheit und der einigkeit soll
ausgehend von diesem gipfeltreffen in
gipfel kulisse das betonen sie hier
heute so oft dass schon allein dadurch
klar wird wie schwer beides zu erreichen
ist und zu bewahren denn auch das wird
hier klar die g7 stellen sich ein auf
eine lange schwierige strecke sie wollen
hier weichen stellen für jahre des
konflikts und der krisen wir werden das
auch morgen wieder für sie begleiten für
heute von uns allen hier danke für das
interesse und in allen ein angenehm habt
[Musik]